[Music]
Michelle Pfeiffer radiating on the cover
of interview magazines April issue it's
hard to believe she's 58 I'm not a big
believer in big potions that are you
know give you eternal youth or something
and the inside shots are just as sunny
oh yeah a long time in the makeup chair
check out these black and white snaps
were loving this one of the seemingly
ageless actress lounging in cheetah
prints of lingerie
makes me real proud this is Michelle's
first interview magazine cover and
nearly 30 years she's also been out of
the spotlight for quite some time but
she's got several projects in the works
including mother alongside Jennifer
Lawrence and HBO's TV movie The Wizard
of lies she says she's ready for a
resurgence quote I'm an empty nester now
I've never lost my love for acting she
shares two kids with husband David E
Kelly and abs I was pretty careful about
where I shot how long I was away whether
or not it worked out with a kids
schedule and I got so picky that I was
unhireable
[Music]